und jetzt rufen wir Oma zum Kaffee und
Kuchen oder ja Mama ich muss sagen der
Kuchen ist schon echt schlecht wir
machen heute einen richtig klassischen
Erdbeerkuchen wie von Oma weil ihr euch
das so gewünscht habt wunderschön sieht
der Obstkuchen aus
11 ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
Erdbeerzeit ist Obstkuchen Zeit Oma
kuchenzeit wir machen heute einen
richtig klassischen Erdbeerkuchen wie
von Oma weil ihr euch das so gewünscht
habt also gibt's einen Kuchenboden für
diese Form nämlich eine Obstkuchenform
das ist so die traditionellste
Kuchenform die ich kenne auf der man
wirklich ganz ganz tolle Obstkuchen
backen kann jetzt geht's mal los mit
meinem Basis Rezept ich habe von diesem
Rezept übrigens auch schon eine vegane
Variante also falls ihr den
obstkuchenboden vegan zubereiten wollt
einfach in Sallys App nachschauen da
gibt's nämlich zu vielen Rezepten auch
bereits schon eine vegane Version dafür
verwende ich 150g weiße Butter 150 g
Zucker etwas Salz und Vanilleextrakt
drei Eier und 25 g Mehl und jetzt nehmt
ihr erstmal die weiche Butter mit Zucker
und Salz und Vanilleextrakt und verrührt
das ganze in der Küchenmaschine ihr seht
ich habe jetzt hier kein Backpulver
aufgeführt und zwar kommt daher wenn ihr
Rührteig zubereitet dann wird das Ganze
eigentlich durch die Butter Zuckermasse
richtig schön schaumig gerührt und man
braucht kein Backpulver früher hat es
die Oma ausgemacht die hat dann
stundenlang die Butter Zuckermasse
gerührt und die Eier reingeschlagen und
man hat kein Backpulver benötigt
irgendwann kam Backpulver mit ins Spiel
und hat da hat man quasi diese Rührzeit
einfach verkürzen können das heißt ihr
könnt entweder ohne Backpulver arbeiten
und das Ganze etwa 10 Minuten lang
richtig weiß cremig rühren damit Luft
eingeschlagen wird oder ihr nehmt
einfach Backpulver dazu oder eben das
backmehl das Backpulver schon enthalten
und könnt die Masse einfach nur zwei
drei Minuten verrühren ein bisschen
cremig das reicht dann auch das dürft
ihr selbst entscheiden
[Musik]
wenn die Butter Zuckermasse dann schön
weiß cremig ist gebt ihr jetzt die Eier
dazu jedes Ei einzeln und dann fällt bei
1 Minute unterrühren damit eine schöne
homogene Masse wird und die Butter eben
nicht gerinnt
[Musik]
super aus guckt euch das mal an
so sollte jetzt die Eier Buttermasse
Aussehen schön geschmeidig und da gebe
ich jetzt das Mehl dazu und rührst nur
noch ganz kurz vorsichtig ein nicht so
lange rühren
[Musik]
Zauberkessel
ist es ja auch im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes
falls ihr auch die Kenwood habt dann
könnt ihr sogar mit einem Programm
arbeiten ihr könnt dann alle Zutaten
reingeben und einen All-in-One Teig
machen und der stellt dann automatisch
die Geschwindigkeit ein ohne das was
raus spritzt und verrührt alle Zutaten
super geht hier auf Programme
auf Biskuitteig ist es zwar kein Biskuit
aber eigentlich meinen die damit
Rührteig und dann habt ihr nämlich hier
einfach alle Zutaten drin drückt auf
Start und dann dauert das ganze nur eine
Minute und ihr habt den Rührteig in
einem All-in-One Teig perfekt
miteinander verrührt ich habe jetzt den
Ofen bereits schon vorgeheizt denn so
einen Rührkuchen sollte immer sofort
gebacken werden immer direkt den Ofen
vorheizen und dann mit dem Rühren
starten ich nehme jetzt eine
Obstkuchenform die wird kurz gefettet
mit backtrennspray
[Musik]
der neue auch hier vorne ein bisschen
verstopft ist dann nehmt ihr einfach
hier vorne diese Düse ab ich merke
gerade das ist nicht so gut sprüht und
dann wascht ihr einfach kurz die Düse
unter heißem Wasser ab ist auch bei
Haarspray oft so dass sich das da gerne
mal festsetzt und da heißes Wasser und
dann kann man es wieder draufsetzen und
dann spritzen
dann noch kurz verteilen
und dann ist der Teig schon bereit für
den Ofen wird gebacken und ich kann in
der Zwischenzeit schon mal die Füllung
vorbereiten denn für meinen Oma echten
Erdbeerkuchen gibt's noch Vanillepudding
richtig cremig
[Musik]
für den Pudding nehme ich 200 g Milch
100 g Sahne ein Eigelb 50g Zucker 30 g
Stärke und natürlich Vanilleextrakt wenn
ihr die Kenwood habt könnt ihr natürlich
auch den Pudding einfach in der Kenwood
kochen bei 90° ich mache das jetzt hier
auf dem Herd damit ihr seht was ich
mache und gebe jetzt erstmal die Milch
in den Topf zum Teil und da rührt ihr
jetzt nämlich alles ein Stärke Zucker
und Eigelb schön Klümpchen rein
und dann gieße ich jetzt die restliche
Milch dazu die Sahne und das
Vanilleextrakt und lass den Pudding
unterrühren aufkochen
[Musik]
wenn der Pudding dann eingedeckt ist
dann einfach kurz umfüllen schön an der
Oberfläche abdecken damit sich keine
Haut bildet und abkühlen lassen
[Musik]
wunderschön sieht der Obstkuchen aus
und da kommt jetzt der Pudding drauf ich
mache es jetzt aber so den habe ich
jetzt abkühlen lassen Pudding ist auch
kalt kommt jetzt direkt mal hier auf
eine schöne Servierplatte ich benutze
meine obstkuchenformen einfach viel zu
wenig wirklich den Pudding jetzt einmal
kurz durchrühren und dann nehmt ihr euch
jetzt direkt eine größere Schüssel macht
es nicht so wie ich im Teller ich bin
Pudding sieht immer bisschen aus wie
Plastik das Eigelb sorgt übrigens für
die schöne Farbe wenn ihr nämlich
Puddingpulver aus der Tüte nehmen dann
ist da meist einfach bisschen Farbstoff
drin muss gar nichts Künstliches sein
kann auch einfach nur ein bisschen z.B
sein und dadurch ist er eben schön gelb
hat so dieses Vanille gelb denn
ursprünglich wurde Pudding eben so
gemacht mit Eigelb
und dieser cremiger Vanillepudding kommt
jetzt hier auf den Tortenboden
[Musik]
wunderbaren die müssen gewaschen werden
und werden dann vom grünen befreit und
halbiert und da drauf gelegt
[Musik]
und jetzt dürft ihr entscheiden ob ihr
den Erdbeerkuchen so servieren wollt
oder ob da noch ein Tortenguss drauf
kommt der Tortenguss sorgt natürlich
dafür dass die Erdbeeren so ein bisschen
konserviert werden die werden geschützt
und trocknen nicht aus falls ihr
Tortenguss absolut nicht mögt empfehle
ich euch die Erdbeeren erst kurz vor dem
Verzehr draufzugeben denn wenn sie jetzt
so bleiben trocknen sie aus und die
Oberfläche die oxidiert einfach es
schmeckt dann nicht mehr so gut das
heißt entweder so lassen und richtig
frisch verzehren also jetzt oder noch in
den Tortenguss draufgeben ich packe dazu
Tortenguss drauf ja und als Alternative
zu Tortenguss falls ihr den wirklich
nicht mögt aber trotzdem vorbereiten
wollt ihr könnt auch Erdbeermarmelade
erhitzen oder Aprikosenmarmelade und das
so ein bisschen drauf streichen oder
Acker Acker einfach nur mit Wasser
aufkochen ein bisschen drüber geben denn
das schützt dann auch ganz gut aber man
hat nicht so diesen Tortenguss Geschmack
wobei ich persönlich Tortenguss ganz
gerne mag deswegen koche ich denn jetzt
und für einen ganz klassischen
Tortenguss nehmt ihr einfach roten
Tortenguss 2 Esslöffel Zucker und 250
Milliliter Wasser oder auch gerne
Fruchtsaft dafür verrührt ihr einfach
das Wasser mit dem Tortenguss Pulver und
dem Zucker in einem Topf lass das Ganze
aufkochen und dann etwa 1 Minute lang
kurz abkühlen zum schnelleren Abkühlen
könnte es auch gerne kurz einfach
umfüllen und ich verteile es dann am
liebsten einfach so mit einem Backpinsel
drüber
da können das nämlich schön dosieren
[Musik]
ich brauche jetzt gar nicht den ganzen
Guss sondern nur so viel dass alle
Erdbeeren schön bedeckt sind das darf
jetzt kurz abkühlen ich gebe dafür die
Torte in den Kühlschrank Schlag dann
noch ein bisschen Sahne mit
Vanilleextrakt auf und dann probieren
wir den Oma Erdbeerkuchen
[Musik]
mein Traum dass ich meine sahne-maschine
habe so wie in der Eisdiele wo man
hingeht und einfach so ein Becher
drunter und sich einfach Sahne Saft
geschlagen wie cool wäre das bitte
willst du den Kuchen probieren
[Applaus]
guck ihn dir an was ist das für ein
Kuchen ein Erdbeerkuchen wie von Oma
ich glaube das sogar besser als Oma also
der sieht auf jeden Fall schon mal
besser aus
also bei uns mag das so stimmen ja weil
meine Mama kocht ja sehr gut ne also
deine Oma und beim Backen ist so
Zitronenkuchen Marmorkuchen Linzer Torte
ist okay und Schokoladenkuchen und
Schokokuchen bei einem anderen habe ich
sie irgendwann überholt aber das ist
okay
trotzdem schmeckt bei Oma alles besser
denn es ist die Oma ich muss das Messer
sauber machen
ist findest du bin ich spießig nein aber
organisiert sein so nein das ist jetzt
dreckig das muss jetzt machen
und dann hat sie noch so ein UNO Spiel
gekauft so ein Kartenspiel und dieses
war so ein laminiert das kann auch eine
Lehrerin machen ich habe es aber nicht
selber ein laminiert das war schon ein
laminiert ich habe nur gesagt die Idee
hatte ich auch schon
aber das schon ein laminiert selber
einlaminieren denn es gab und ohne Spiel
zum Kaufen extra für den Strand weil man
immer und überall spielen kann
und was fehlt jetzt noch natürlich Sahne
okay
[Musik]
und Sahne schmecken noch
gut
und jetzt das Urteil unserer Fachjury
Samira ist schon ihre Wertung bitte
meine Wertung ist es gibt maximal zehn
Punkte
[Musik]
also wenn ihr diesem Rezept auch eine 11
von 10 gibt dann schaut gerne auf Sallys
App vorbei oder auf sallys-blog.de falls
ihr die Webversion sehen wollt dort
gibt's das Rezept für euch ich habe die
Backform übrigens auch in 28 cm benutzt
ihr könnt auch eine kleine nehmen können
das Rezept ganz einfach umrechnen in
meiner App das funktioniert alles ganz
automatisch ich bin jedenfalls schon
richtig gespannt auf euren Erdbeerkuchen
und sagt mir doch mal gerne worin
beziehungsweise in welchem Rezept ihr
die Erdbeeren bisher am meisten mochtet
der Kuchen klingelt der Ofen klingelt
der Kuchen ist fertig ich muss weiter
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
und jetzt ruf mal Oma zum Kaffee Kuchen
oder Mama ich muss sagen der Kuchen ist
schon echt ja was heißt das jetzt wird
euch das jetzt wieder so eine
Jugendsprache ja was heißt das
sehr toll